The joe rogan experience.
Kevin just gave me a heart
attack and he did his name,
realize it.
What way and what was I talking
about it all that life thing.
I almost died a Friday night.
I,
uh,
was out in,
just told me and I'm like,
uh,
I was at a karaoke bar in Burbank
right across the street from a,
the Jay Leno show,
like the NBC building temples.
I've see,
I've,
see,
I drive past that.
I've seen that place.
I came out,
me and my girlfriend around 1130 and
we walking out the front and we parked.
So I'm opening the door for her
to get in Avondale where this big,
tall black guy,
about six to wearing a fake gray beard,
like a Santa Claus beard that was like
tied on with white strings and a hat in
this big Hobo jacket shows a
gun in my chest and was like,
give me your fucking wallet.
Oh man,
you're harsher.
My boss.
Yeah.
And they keep going.
And then my girlfriend,
my girlfriend was,
my girlfriend was pretty drunk.
That's good.
Here's my girlfriend was pretty drunk,
so because,
uh,
she has like social anxiety,
so she drinks,
you know,
when she goes out,
she thought it was a joke.
She looked over and thought this
was like a character or something.
Right.
And so he's like,
do shit,
you're shaking him can tell.
It's still fun fucking night.
That would fuck me up.
Keep going.
And so he said,
uh,
he said,
um,
you know,
give me your fucking purse bitch.
And she just like,
like looking at like what?
Like she was drunk and
shocked and I'm like,
give her,
give him the person.
So I get gave her or she gave
him the purse and then he goes,
get in the car,
lay on your fucking stomach.
And he's shoving the gun in my
back while I'm laying in the car.
And I'm thinking like,
all right,
this is like execution style.
Like he's telling me,
you know,
get in there and then suddenly he goes,
get laid down to the,
to my girlfriend.
And she laid down on her back
because she was just so freaked out.
He said,
I said later on your
fucking stomach bitch.
And he's like,
it's just shoving a gun in her back.
And then finally just like both laying
there and then he slams the door and then
just takes off.
And so now,
like the other day I was at the grocery
store and I saw a black guy that was
tall and I'm now I'm like freaking out.
Like if it was a redhead that robbed
me would have been the same way.
But now I see these guys and I'm like
becoming like a racist from the 50s now
where I'm like walking around like
what's he doing on my side of the store?
You know like it's great.
It's like at this point you had your,
you were in that moment.
Yeah.
What did you,
what was it like?
It was really when I was laying there
and it was like this is it and you think
that,
what did you think?
You know,
I didn't think about anything
except my girlfriend the whole time.
And I'm like,
cause hearing him yell at her,
that's just you.
You think that you can just going to
look around and look for a weapon or
something like that,
but when you're in that biggest shock,
you're just like,
oh,
I wouldn't look to fence lines,
so not the butch do that again.
There's that word.
I am showing up the dude that's like,
where's a weapon?
I'm going to do this.
My immediate,
my reaction is going to be like,
let me suck your Dick.
Let us go.
I will suck your Dick until you let us go.
And he's like,
you've got a girlfriend.
I'm like,
still,
I'll be better than her.
Yeah,
I can really deliver.
I,
that's where I go with it.
I would never go defensive or office.
All these people online.
Of course I was like,
what'd you give for not doing Jujitsu?
If I had two guns in my pocket,
I still [inaudible] you add
yourself strapped the dynamite,
maybe then you can be a
little look at this bitch,
right?
Yeah.
People are those you should have,
people should shut the fuck up.
No one knows what that's like
until that happens to you.
And you should always give
someone what they want.
Usually they just want to fucking
get your money and run away.
They don't want to shoot you.
Is that the case?
Usually hear right once in a while though,
like,
like Old Lady,
you know,
did nothing still gets shot
or something like that.
So if it's a young kid on fucking PCP,
it's really a gamble.
This is in Burbank.
And then time where you believing about
midnight and three months before that or
six months before that I was in
Fuddruckers in Burbank and some guys like
stealing this girl's person running
out the door and I'm chasing him.
I'm like,
I'm in Burbank right now.
Why?
You know,
and we talked about,
uh,
the Kmart shooting in one podcast,
the,
there was a shooting at Kmart in Burbank.
And the officer that got shot was
the one that came to rescue me when,
uh,
the other night.
And I was like,
you're the,
you're the one officer.
And he's like,
yeah,
I got shot in the leg and stuff like that.
And so he became like a celebrity guy.
Well,
he's been shot at in Burbank and,
and Kmarts like,
you know [inaudible] he saw
him on TV like they showed us.
But,
but it's like,
it's like,
it seems like you always
hear Burbank is so sad.
Yeah.
You'll,
you don't think of Burbank is
like Bob hope and live there.
How could it be right
there could be no terror.
Well Toluca Lake,
I wonder how many checks
one of bone that guy,
because he's the straight
celebrity cop that got shot.
Well,
I had to wait a bunch,
right?
Gotta be right.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck fat dude.
Gotta be chicks that wanna
fuck fucking hero cop.
He wrote cop that got shot in the leg.
I bet that guy gets beaten off the
pussy just waiting for forensics.
Like I had to wait like
four hours because,
I mean,
this is like,
they closed off helicopters and everything
that was at cops and stuff and then
they wanted a fingerprint,
my car.
So I'm just sitting there
and he's like going,
asking my girlfriend like
questions like weird questions.
Like,
so what do you do?
Oh,
you're like dance at,
Huh?
Yo Yo,
you ain't,
and stuff like it was,
no,
he was totally an awesome,
nice cop.
But it was kind of weird like hearing
like my girlfriend having to talk like it
was an exotic dancer.
No,
but just asking weird questions and then
it was easy going as close to hitting
on her as he could and
still remaining a cop.
What's he doing?
Ain't with this guy.
I don't know.
If you see me and they see my girlfriend,
maybe he thought I paid for her,
like if she was a hooker or something,
you know,
like how long do you know this guy?
You've got it
exactly in Brian Flux.
Way over his head.
But,
but what's weird is,
I don't even know what,
it's weird.
Oh,
but we're just saying,
he was talking to me and asking me
all these questions and he goes,
well,
and I was like,
yeah,
I would like to be a cop,
but I like marijuana too much.
And he goes,
yeah,
I see that know marijuana.
And he's like,
it's gonna be legal soon.
So don't worry about that.
And I was like,
all right,
just office Korea.
I don't know if he's got
a fucking crystal ball.
Yeah,
come on,
man.
Come on.
I was the only silver lining to that
horrible story was like at the end of it,
the cop was like,
don't worry,
kid.
One day it's going to be leaving now.
I'm scared of black wizards.
Wizards,
wizard.
It's the screen.
Let's get it going to be an Internet meme.
My friend black wizards.
You're scared of monsters,
you know like smoking.
[inaudible] scared of werewolves,
Bro.
I love you.
I'm scared of Jaguars and pants.
Did you see one?
A monster?
You see the video?
I tweeted the other day of a
Jaguar killing a fucking crocodile.
Yes.
[inaudible]
okay.